if the angles a B and C of a triangle
are in an arithmetic progression and if
a B and C lowercase a B and C denote the
lengths of the sides opposite to the
capital the angles a capital a capital B
and capital C respectively then what is
the value of this expression right over
here so let's see if we can work our way
through this so let's just draw the
triangle just so we have a visualization
of what all of the letters represent so
we have the angles a B and C so let me
just draw them like this so we have the
angles a B and C and then the sides
opposite them or the lowercase version
so the side opposite to capital a is
lowercase a side opposite to capital B
is lowercase B and the side opposite to
the angle capital C is lowercase C now
the first piece of information they tell
us is that they the angles capital a
capital B and capital C of the triangle
are an arithmetic progression arithmetic
progression very fancy word but all an
arithmetic progression is is a series of
numbers that are separated by the same
amount so and let me give you some
examples so 1 2 3 that's an arithmetic
progression 2 4 6 arithmetic progression
we're separated by 2 every time I could
do 10-20-30
also an arithmetic progression these are
all arithmetic progressions so all
they're saying is is to go from angle a
to angle B however much that is it's the
same amount to go from angle B to angle
C so let's see what what that tells us
what that tells us about or maybe tells
us maybe doesn't tell us anything about
those angles so if we could say we could
say we have angle a and then we have the
notion angle B so we could say that B is
equal to a plus some constant we don't
know what that is it could go up by one
it could go up by 2 it could go by 10 we
don't know what it is so a plus N and
then C would be equal to B plus n which
is the same thing which is the same
thing as B is a plus n so this is a plus
plus n which is equal to a plus 2n so
what does that do us well the other
thing we know about three angles and the
triangles that they have to add up to
180 degrees so this this and this have
to add up to 180 degrees so let's try it
out so we have a plus a plus n plus a
plus 2n plus a plus 2n is going to be
equal to 180 degrees we have one two
three A's here so we get three a plus we
have one N and then another two n 3 a
plus 3 n is equal to 180 degrees or you
could divide both sides by 3 and you get
a plus n is equal to a plus n is equal
to 60 degrees so what is that what does
that tell us well it could still be
anything because if n is 1 then a is 59
if n is 10 then a is going to be 50 so
it doesn't to give us much information
about the angle a but if you look up
here do you see an A plus at anywhere
well you see it right over here b is
equal to a plus N and we just figured
out that a plus n has to be equal to 60
degrees so using this first piece of
information we were able to come up with
something pretty tangible B must be
equal to 60 degrees and you could try it
out with a bunch of numbers these could
be 59 60 and 61
that's an arithmetic progression and
once again B is the middle one right
over here
these could be 50 60 and 70 could be 40
60 and 80 but no matter what the
arithmetic progression is in order for
these three angles to add up to 180 the
middle one has to be equal to has to be
equal to 60 degrees so that was a pretty
that's what we're doing pretty well so
far so let's see what we can do it the
next part with the next part of the
problem and I'm trying to save some
screen real estate right over here
okay so they want us to figure out the
value of the expression a over C sine of
two C capital C plus C over a sine of 2a
so let's let me just write it down so we
have I'll do it in
I'll do it in blue a oversee a oversee
sine of two times capital C plus C over
a sine of two times capital A what's
that going to be equal to so whenever
you see stuff like this you got a two
here two here frankly the best things
you do is just experiment with your
trigonometric identities and see if
anything pops out at you that might be
useful and a little bit of a clue here
the first part of the problem helped us
figure out what B is it helped us figure
out what B is but right now the
expression has no B in it so right now
this information seems kind of useless
but if we could put this somehow in
terms of B then we'll have we'll we'll
be making progress because we know
information about angle B so let's see
what we can do so the first thing I
would use is well sine of 2a so let me
just rewrite each of these so sine of I
should say tyne of two times anything
that's just the same thing as I think
this is called the double angle formula
so this is although I might be wrong
there I always forget the actual names
of them but sine of two times something
is 2 sine of that something times the
cosine of that times the cosine of that
something and you'll see that in any
trigonometric book on the inside cover
or even a lot of calculus books let's do
that for this the same thing right over
here so sine of 2a over here is going to
be 2 sine of a cosine of a that's just a
standard trigonometric identity and we
in the trigonometric playlist we prove
that identity I think we do it multiple
times and then out in front we have our
coefficient still we have a over C times
this plus C over a times this now is
there anything we can do and remember in
the back of our mind we should be
thinking of how can we use this
information that B is equal to 60 so if
we can somehow put this in the form get
a B here and when I think about how do
you get a B here I think well you know
we have a triangle here so the things
that relate the sides of a triangle when
especially when it's not a right
triangle is we're going to deal with the
law of sines or the law of cosines and
the law of sines let me just rewrite it
over here just for our reference so the
law of sines would say sine of
a over a is equal to sine of B over B
which is equal to sine of C over C and
it looks like we might be able to use
that let me just write the law of
cosines here just in case it's useful in
the future so the law of cosines C
squared it's really the Pythagorean
theorem it's a little adjustment for the
fact that it's not a right triangle so C
squared is equal to a squared plus b
squared minus 2a B cosine cosine of C of
capital C so it's law of sines and law
of cosines so let's see if we can
somehow use both of these to put these
in terms of B which we have information
about well the first thing is I could
rewrite this so this says sine of c over
c and this is sine of a over a so let me
do that so i have let me do this so I
have the 2a I have 2a cosine of C let me
write that separately so I have 2a
cosine cosine of capital C and then
times sine of C over C times I'll do
that in white sine of C that's a capital
C sine of capital C over lowercase C
that's that term and that term right
over there and then to that I'm adding
to that I'm adding I'm gonna do the same
thing over here I have to times I'm
going to separate these guys out
actually now I want to do the signs so
let me separate I'm going to separate
this guy and this guy out and so I get
plus 2 C cosine of a times sine of
capital a over lowercase a times sine of
capital a over a lowercase a now what
did this do for me well look at the law
so look at the law of sines right over
there I have sine of C over C that's
that over there and then I have sine of
a over AI that's that over there capital
a over lowercase a they're both equal to
sine of B over B so we're making
progress we have--we've relate we
started introduced B into the equation
and that's or the expression and that's
what we actually have information about
so this could be re-written as sine of B
over
B so this is the same thing as sine of
capital B over lowercase B and this is
the same thing as sine of capital B over
lowercase B and they're both being
multiplied or both of these terms are
multiplying are being multiplied by that
2a cosine of capital C times that and
then plus 2c2 lowercase e cosine of
capital a times that so we can factor
out the sine of b over b so let's do
that let's factor it out so this is the
same thing as this is the same thing as
2a 2a and I already have a sense of what
the next step is I'm leave a little
space here to a times cosine of C plus
this and these are being multiplied I
left some space there plus 2c2 lowercase
e times the cosine times the cosine of a
and all of this all of this times the
sine the sine of B over B and we know we
already know that B is 60 degrees so we
can evaluate this pretty pretty easily
but let's just let's just continue see
if we can somehow somehow put this right
over here in terms of B well if you look
over here we have 2a cosine of C - C
cosine of a it looks it's starting to
look pretty darn close pretty darn close
each of these terms look pretty darn
close to this part to this part of the
law of cosines over there and actually
let's let's solve for that part of the
law of cosines
let's see what we could do so if you add
if you add to a B cosine C to both sides
you get to a B cosine of capital C plus
C squared is equal to a squared plus B
squared or if you subtract c squared
from both sides you get 2a B cosine of
capital C is equal to a squared plus B
squared minus C squared and this is
interesting and we can you know switch
around the letters later on but this
looks pretty darn close to this so what
if and this looks pretty darn close to
this except
here we're dealing with an a instead of
a c we've just switched the letters
around and we could rewrite this
actually let me rewrite it just for fun
I could rewrite this over here as 2 to
see B not rewrite it I can swap the
letters times the cosine of a so here
I'm swapping the A's and the C's is
equal to C squared plus B squared minus
a squared there's nothing unique about
the side see I can do this with all of
the sides so here when you have a big C
here you have an A and a B out front and
then you have the a squared plus B
squared minus the small C squared if you
have a big A then you can have the C be
in the front and then you're subtracting
the a squared right over here and this
is useful because this term right over
here this term right over here it looks
almost like this term over here if we
just have to if we could just multiply
this by B so let's do that we can
multiply that by B right let's multiply
this whole numerator this whole term by
B so if we multiply this whole term by B
what do we get we get to be there we get
a B there and of course you can't just
arbitrarily multiply an expression by B
that'll change its value so what we can
do is multiply the expression by B which
we just did we distributed the B across
here but then we'll also divide by B
which so I'll divide by B that's the
equivalent of multiplying the
denominator the denominator there not B
squared that's the equivalent of
multiplying the denominator there by B
that's the same thing as dividing by B
we've multiplied by B divided by B or
that's the same thing as just turning
this into B squared now what does this
give us well we have this term right
over here this term right over here is
now the exact same thing as that over
there so it is now a squared plus B
squared minus C squared and then this
term right over here is now the exact
same thing as this thing over here which
is the same thing as that we're using
the law of cosines so this is plus C
squared plus B squared minus a squared
and then all of that times this sine of
B sine of capital B over B squared now
what does this give us the we have an a
squared and a negative a squared things
learning to simplify a squared negative
a squared we have a negative C squared
and a positive C squared so what are we
left with we're just left with a 2b
squared so our whole expression has
simplified to 2b squared sine of B sine
of capital B over lowercase B squared
these cancel out so our whole expression
simplifies to 2 sine of B and from from
the get-go we knew what B was we know
it's 60 degrees so this is equal to 2
times the sine of 60 degrees and if you
don't have the sine of 60 degrees
memorized you can always just break out
a 30-60-90 triangle so let me draw this
is a right triangle right over here this
is 60 degrees hypotenuse has length 1
we're dealing with the unit circle the
this side is 30 degrees the side
opposite the 30 degrees is 1/2 the side
opposite the 60 degrees is square root
of 3 times at so it's square root of 3
over 2 you can even use the Pythagorean
theorem to figure out once you know one
of them you could figure out the other
one so it's the sine of sine is opposite
over hypotenuse so square root of 3 over
2 over 1 or it's just square root of 3
over 2 so this is equal to 2 times is
the homestretch it's very exciting
square root of 3 over 2
these cancel out so we are left with the
square root of 3 that's a that's a
pretty neat problem and just in case
you're curious this came from the 2010
IIT IITs are these hard to get into
engineering and science universities in
India and they give you this exam to
like you know hundreds of thousands of
kids and you know the top the top I
don't know like 2,000 actually get into
one of the IITs but I just thought it
was a pretty pretty neat problem